MICHALE FEE: Good
morning, everybody.
So we're going to
continue today developing
our model of a neuron.
Again, this is called the
"Equivalent Circuit Model,"
and it was developed by Alan
Hodgkin and Andrew Huxley
in the '40s and '50s.
Let me just give a brief
recap of what we've covered
in the last couple of lectures.
So we've been
analyzing a neuron.
We've been imagining an
experiment in which we
have a neuron in a dish filled
with extracellular solution,
which is a salt solution.
We have an electrode
in the cell that's
measuring the voltage
difference between the inside
and the outside of the cell.
So we have the
electrode connected
to an amplifier, a differential
amplifier, and a wire
in the bath connected to the
other side of the differential
amplifier.
And we have a
current source, which
injects current into the cell.
And we imagine that,
as the experimenter,
we have our hand
on a knob that we
can adjust the amount
of current that's
being injected into the cell.
We've described the
neuron basically
as a capacitor,
because it has a--
it's two conductors
separated by an insulator.
So we have a conductor, one
conductor inside the cell,
which is that conductive
intracellular salt solution,
and another conductor
outside the cell, which
is the conductive
extracellular solution.
And those two
conductors are separated
by an insulator, which is
a phospholipid bilayer.
We wrote down the
equivalent circuit
for this, which for this
situation right here
it has a voltage measuring
device that represents
the membrane potential
as the difference
between the intracellular
voltage and the extracellular
voltage.
We have a current
source here, and we've
represented our neuron
so far as a capacitor.
We then introduce the idea of
ion channels, or conductances,
or pores in the
membrane that allow
ions to pass through
the membrane,
through these little pores.
And we described the
idea that there are--
we talked about the idea that
there are many different kinds
of ions, ion channels, that
have different interesting
properties.
So we then extended our
analysis of our neuron
in the dish to include
these ion channels.
We began by putting--
by representing ion
channels as a resistance
that connects the
intracellular space.
In the extracellular
space, this resistor
is in parallel
with our capacitor.
And we represented
the current going
through that
resistance, which we
called the "leak
resistance," R sub
L. We represented the current
as "leak current," I sub L.
We noted that we were
going to model this leak
resistance using Ohm's law.
So we wrote down
that current, that
leak current, as the
membrane potential, V,
divided by the leak resistance.
So this is just Ohm's law.
And we also rewrote
the quantity 1
over R, 1 over the resistance,
as the leak conductance.
So the leak current is
just the leak conductance
times the membrane potential.
And we also introduced the
idea of an I-V curve, which
plots the amount
of current flowing
through our leak conductance
here as a function
of the membrane
potential, this V.
And for the case of a resistor,
for the case where we're
modeling our leak
conductance with Ohm's law,
the current, as a
function of voltage,
is a straight line going through
the origin, whose slope is just
the leak conductance.
Any questions about that?
Then we derived
a simple equation
for how the membrane potential
evolves over time as a function
of the injected current.
And we did that using
Kirchhoff's current law, which
says that the sum of all
the currents into a node
has to equal the sum of
currents out of a node,
where a node here means a wire.
And so the sum of these
occurrences equal to 0.
There's a minus sign here,
because this current,
the electrode injected current,
is defined as positive going
into the cell,
and these currents
are defined as positive when
they go out of the cell.
We substituted for
the leak current,
the expression from Ohm's law.
So into this part of the
equation here, this term,
we substitute VM
over R sub L. And I
apologize for the slight
inconsistency in notation here.
Sometimes I'm using
VM, and sometimes I'm
using V. I'll try to
fix that, but those--
VM is the same as V in
what you've seen so far.
And we also have
an expression here
for the capacitive current.
The capacitive current
through this capacitor
is just C, dV, dt.
So we put those two expressions,
make those two substitutions,
and we have this expression that
relates the voltage in the cell
to the injected current.
We rewrote this a little
bit by multiplying through
by the leak resistance, and
we rewrote this again making
a couple substitutions.
We use tau in place of RC.
So that becomes a time constant.
And the infinity is this
expression on the right--
R leak times the
injected current.
So the equation
that we now have,
the differential
equation that we now
have, for the dependence of
the membrane potential on
injected current
looks like this--
V plus tau, dV, dt, is
equal to V infinity.
When we inject
current into the cell,
we're changing the infinity.
And then the voltage
evolves, as described
by this differential equation.
So we're going to plot a
bunch of things, the infinity
and the voltage in the cell, as
we inject a pulse of current.
So we start out with
injected current equal to 0.
We step up to I naught, hold
a constant injected current I
naught for some period of time,
and then reset the current back
to 0.
So what does V infinity do as
a function of time, anybody?
What does that mean?
AUDIENCE: It does
the same things.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
It does the same thing,
but multiplied by R sub L--
very good.
And what does the
membrane potential do?
So let's start the
membrane potential at 0.
So starting here, what does
the membrane potential do
[INAUDIBLE]?
Yes?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm Kate.
MICHALE FEE: Kate.
Yes, stays at 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
How do we say--
how do we say it?
Exponentially toward
V infinity, very good.
So it relaxes exponentially
toward infinity, which is here.
And then what happens?
AUDIENCE: And then
it [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Very good.
And it does-- it relaxes
with a time constant of RC.
And what that means
is that the time
it takes for it to relax to 1
over e of its original distance
from V infinity is given by tau.
Very good-- and you can solve
this differential equation
that was on the previous
slide for periods
where the injected
current is constant,
where V infinity is constant.
And what you can see is
that the voltage difference
from the current V infinity
relaxes exponentially to 0.
It starts out at the initial
voltage minus V infinity,
and you multiply that difference
times an exponential that
decays to 0.
And so the voltage difference
between the voltage and V
infinity decreases.
So now we then
introduce the idea
that neurons have batteries.
Where do the
batteries of a neuron
come from, anybody remember?
Stacey, I remember you.
Where do the batteries
of a neuron come from?
Good.
That's what the
battery produces.
The battery produces
a voltage difference.
But biophysically, what causes
that voltage difference?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good,
ion selective pores.
Good, that's one
component, and there's
another important component.
Somebody else want to answer?
AUDIENCE: Ion concentration.
MICHALE FEE: Good, excellent.
So we have two components--
ion concentration gradients
and ions selective pores.
So basically, if you have a
high concentration of potassium
inside the cell, when you open
up a potassium selective ion
channel, the potassium ions
diffuse out of the cell,
leaving an excess
of negative charges
inside the cell that causes
the voltage inside the cell
to go down until there's
a sufficient voltage
gradient that the drift
of potassium ions back
into the cell driven
by the voltage gradient
is equal to the
diffusion rate of ions
out of the cell produced by
the concentration gradient.
At equilibrium, at the
equilibrium potential,
there's a particular
voltage at which
there is no net current into--
potassium current into
or out of the cell.
And that's what we mean
by equilibrium potential,
otherwise known as the
"Nernst potential."
Last time we derived
the Nernst potential
using the Boltzmann equation.
The Boltzmann equation
gives us the ratio
of the probability of finding
an ion inside or outside
of the cell, and that's equal
to e to the minus energy
difference of an ion inside
and outside of the cell divided
by KT.
The energy difference
is given by the charge
times the voltage difference,
the charge of the ion
that we're considering times
the voltage difference.
So we took the log of both
sides, solved for V in minus V
out, and we found that
the voltage difference
at equilibrium.
This is at thermal equilibrium.
That's what the Boltzmann
equation tells us--
at thermal equilibrium.
What's the ratio
of probabilities?
At thermal equilibrium,
the voltage difference
is 25,000 millivolts times
the log, the natural log,
of the ratio of
concentrations, and that's
E sub K. If you plug-in the
potassium concentrations here,
that gives you the equilibrium
potential for potassium
or the Nernst potential
for potassium.
So real neurons
here on Earth are
kind of like caesium
neurons on that--
cesium ions on
that alien planet.
The potassium concentration
inside of a cell
is around 400
millimolar, and I think
this is for squid giant axon,
which is a little bit alien.
Yes?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: From the
previous [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Yep.
So if you think
about the probability
of finding a potassium
ion inside of a cell
and finding a potassium
ion outside of the cell,
the ratio of
probabilities is going
to be proportional to the
ratio of concentrations.
Does that make sense?
So given these concentrations,
a high concentration
of positive potassium
ions inside the cell,
a low concentration
outside the cell,
we can take the ratio
of those concentrations,
take the natural log of that.
That's about 3 log units.
The sign is negative, because
this ratio is smaller than 1.
So the equilibrium
potential for potassium
is about 25 millivolts, KT
over Q for a monovalent iron
is 25 millivolts.
So the Nernst potential is
25 millivolts times minus 3.
So the equilibrium
potential is about minus 75.
So let's now look at a
different ion, sodium.
So sodium has a very
low concentration inside
of a cell compared to outside.
That ratio is about
a factor of 10.
The natural log of 10 is
about 2 log units, right?
So what's the
equilibrium potential
for sodium, anybody has a guess?
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
Plus or minus?
AUDIENCE: Oh, plus.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
So it's about 2 log units
times 25 millivolts, right?
So it's plus 50 or so.
Good.
How about chloride?
So this is interesting.
Chloride is a negative ion.
It has a high concentration
outside the cell
and a low concentration
inside the cell.
So when we open up a
chloride channel, what
happens to the chloride ions?
Which way do they go, into
the cell or out of the cell?
Good.
They're negative.
So what is that going to do to
the voltage inside the cell?
We're negative, good.
And the ratio of concentrations
here is about 10.
So log of 10.
It's 2-ish.
So what's that Nernst
potential going to be?
About minus 50, exactly.
If you plug-in the actual
numbers, it's minus 60.
Great.
Good.
Here's an interesting
one-- calcium.
Calcium is kept at an
extremely low concentration
inside of cells, because it's
used as a signaling molecule.
When calcium comes into
a cell, it actually
does things important.
So the cell buffers calcium.
It sequesters calcium into
the endoplasmic reticulum
and keeps the concentration
in the cytoplasm very low.
The concentration outside
the cell is about 2.
The ratio is a
pretty big number.
So if you--
OK.
Why is the coefficient
here, KT over Q,
why is that 12 millivolts
here instead of 25?
Excellent.
So it's KT over 2 times
the electron charge.
So that's 12
millivolts, very good.
And so the equilibrium potential
for calcium is very positive.
Great.
Any questions about that?
So these are the
most important ions
that we have to think about
in terms of ionic conductances
across the membrane.
Any questions?
Good.
So let's go back to
our neuron in the dish,
and we're going to consider
a neuron that has a potassium
conductance and a high potassium
concentration inside the cell.
Remember, we can write
down the magnitude
of that conductance
as G sub K. And now
we're going to do an experiment.
We're going to
measure the voltage
in our cell, the steady
state voltage in our cell,
as a function of the
amount of current that
is either being injected or
passing through the membrane--
its steady state.
Those two things are the same.
So we're going to plot
the potassium current
through the membrane
as a function
of the voltage of the cell.
So let's say that
we inject 0 current.
What's the steady state voltage
in the cell going to be,
anybody?
We just went through this.
Uh-oh, I have to--
oh, OK.
I have a volunteer back here.
Why 25 millivolts?
And we will assume
the channel is open.
So what is the--
so your answer is that the--
if you inject 0
current, the voltage
is going to be the Nernst
potential for potassium.
And that is correct, but
what is the actual number?
Good.
It's going to be around
negative 75 millivolts.
So if we inject 0 current, we
know a voltage of our neuron
is going to be around EK
or minus 75 millivolts.
Now, let's start injecting
current into the cell
until the voltage gets to 0.
Now, are we going
to be injecting
positive current into this
cell or negative current?
What do we have to do, inject
positive or negative current
to make the voltage get up to 0?
Positive, right, because the
voltage inside is negative.
So we need to inject
positive charges.
And how much current
do we need to inject?
If the conductance is
g, how much current
do we need to inject?
What?
V is the voltage inside of our
cell, so you're getting there.
You're really close.
What's the answer?
A times G. So we're going
to inject the current
into our cell until
the voltage gets to 0.
And if we inject different
amounts of current
into the cell and measure
what the voltage is,
we get kind of a straight line.
So for a potassium
conductance, if you
hold the voltage positive above
the equilibrium potential,
potassium ions are going to
flow out through the membrane.
Is that clear?
Let's hold the voltage at 0.
Which way are our ions flowing?
So the ions are going
to be flowing out.
To hold the voltage
at EK, what happens
to the potassium current?
It goes to 0, because you're
now at the Nernst potential.
And if you hold the voltage
below, the inside of the cell
is now negative relative
to the Nernst potential,
and current's going to flow in.
So notice that the
current actually
reverses sine around EK.
And so sometimes this voltage
is called the "reversal
potential."
So you'll hear me sometimes
refer to the reversal
potential, and that's just the
same as the Nernst potential
or the equilibrium potential.
So the equation
for something that
looks like this, a straight
line that's offset from 0,
is just this.
So this expression
right here is going
to be our basic model
for how we describe
the current through an
ion channel as a function
of the voltage of the membrane.
So current, the
potassium current,
is just the
potassium conductance
times the difference of
the membrane potential
from the reversal potential.
So IK equals GK
times V minus EK.
We also have a circuit, a little
simple equivalent circuit,
that describes this relation,
and this is what it looks like.
We have a-- what
we're going to do
to include the effects of
this ion-specific conductance
in the presence of a
concentration gradient
is to take our conductor, our
resistor here, our conductance,
and put it in series
with a battery.
So that's the basic
circuit element
that describes this
kind of I-V relation.
Why is that?
So let's break this
down a little bit.
Basically, what
we're going to do
is we're going to equate this
membrane potential difference
between the inside and
the outside of the cell,
this potential difference, to
the sum of the voltage drops
across these two elements.
Is it 1.5 volts, the same
as the battery in here?
No.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
That's the battery we've
been talking about, exactly.
So the voltage drop
across this battery is EK.
What's the voltage drop across
this resistor, this potassium
conductance?
What does it depend on?
What if the current is 0?
What's the voltage drop across
a resistor whose current is 0?
0.
Ohm's law, right?
What is it at arbitrary current?
What's the voltage
drop across a resistor
as a function of current?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
Can somebody tell me what it
is in terms of the quantities
that we have?
We're looking for a
delta V across here.
So VM, the membrane
potential, has
to just equal the sum of those
two voltage drops, right?
So VM equals EK plus IK over GK.
And now let's just
solve this for IK.
So that's why this little
circuit element describes
our potassium conductance.
That's the equation
that goes with it.
Any questions?
No?
All right, let's push on.
This quantity right here,
by the way, V minus EK,
is called the driving potential.
If V is equal to EK, then
the driving potential is 0,
and there's no current.
The current through the channel
is proportional to the driving
potential.
So let's just-- so
there is our new circuit
diagram for our cell that's a
capacitor whose membrane has
little leaks in
it, where there's
a ion-specific permeability of
the pore and ion concentration
gradient to produce a battery.
There's our new circuit element.
You can see that we're
getting awfully close now
to the whole equivalent
circuit model that Hodgkin
and Huxley wrote down.
So let's just flesh
out this equation here.
What is I sub K?
I sub K is just times
V minus EK, very good.
Remember that the resistance,
RK is just 1 over GK,
and tau, again, is
RK times C. So let's
massage this a little bit more.
We're going to write
this down as V plus dV,
dt equals EK plus RKIE.
So what is that?
Any guess what that is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Very good.
Can everyone see why
that's V infinity?
Because if you set
dV, dt equal to 0,
V is equal to IK plus RKIE.
If you inject a constant
current at steady state,
dV, dt equals 0, you can see
that the injected current
is just equal to the
potassium current
leaking out through
the membrane.
That all makes great sense.
So that's V infinity.
The voltage is just--
the differential equation
is V plus tau dV,
dt equals V infinity.
It's exactly the same
equation we had before.
So you know that at every moment
V is going to be doing what?
Everybody together-- relaxing
toward V infinity, right?
Where that's our new V infinity.
So we're going to do the
same experiment again.
Here is our pulse
of injected current.
V infinity is now
starting at EK,
jumps up to EK plus RKI naught
and then goes back down.
And the voltage of the cell
is relaxing toward V infinity.
So adding that just shifted
this voltage trace down from 0.
Remember, before this
was sitting at 0,
and now it's sitting
at minus 75 millivolts.
Any questions?
So we're going to
come back in a minute
and finish fleshing
out this model where
we make those conductances
is dependent on time
as a way of describing the
spikes that a neuron produces.
But before we do
that, we're going
to talk about a much
simpler model of how
a spiking neuron behaves.
Basically, what we're going
to do is we're going to
instead of write down a detailed
biophysical model of action
potentials, which is
where we're heading,
we're just going to ask some
simpler questions about how
a spiking neuron behaves.
So notice that action
potentials are really important.
They're the way neurons
communicate with other neurons.
They send a signal down their
axon, release neurotransmitter
on other neurons.
But most of the time a
neuron is not spiking.
What is it doing?
Well, could be.
Other thoughts?
Certainly sometimes
it could be resting.
Right.
Well, and how does it do that?
[LAUGHS]
It's part of it.
Anybody?
Yes?
Integrating its inputs, and
it integrates those inputs,
and eventually it spikes.
So we're going to
develop a model
or look at a model now called,
not surprisingly, "integrate
and fire," that captures
exactly that idea.
That a neuron spends most of
its time integrating its inputs,
making a decision
about when to spike,
and then spiking, and
then starting over again.
So the other crucial
piece of this
is that for most
types of neurons
the spikes are
really all the same.
The details of the
spike wave form
don't carry extra
information beyond the fact
that there's a spike.
We're going to treat our
spikes as delta functions, just
discrete events
at a single time,
and the spikes
are going to occur
when the voltage in
the neuron reaches
a particular membrane potential,
called the "spike threshold."
Now, that's a reasonable
approximation for many neurons.
It's not absolutely the
case, but many neurons
spike when the neuron reaches
a particular voltage threshold.
And that's captured in this
model called the integrate
and fire neuron.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to take our
Hodgkin-Huxley model,
and we're going to replace
these sodium and potassium
conductances that actually
generate the spike.
We're going to replace
that with a very simplified
model of a spike generator, and
it's going to look like this.
So basically, the idea is
that the cell gets input
from either an electrode
or from a synaptic input,
and it integrates that input
until it reaches a voltage,
called V threshold.
And once it reaches a
threshold, we simply
reset the voltage back down to
a lower value, called "V reset."
And then we just--
if we want to, we can just
draw a line at that time,
and that's the spike.
But what really happens
to the voltage here
is that once the voltage
hits V threshold,
it gets reset back down
to this [INAUDIBLE]..
Any questions?
Now, that kind of
behavior is not--
it's fairly common in neurons.
So this is an example of, does
the voltage in a cell in motor
cortex of the
songbird-- and this
is from a paper from Rich
Mooney's lab back in 1992.
And you can see that
if you inject current,
the voltage in this cell ramps
up until it hits a threshold
voltage.
It makes a spike, which is
very narrow in time, but then
the voltage resets down
to a lower voltage.
And that process just
repeats over and over.
So now what we're
going to do is we're
going to calculate the rate
at which a neuron fires
as a function of how
much current gets
injected into the cell,
how much input a cell gets.
So we're going to
start by considering
the case where the cell has
no leaks in its membrane,
no conductances.
So let's plot voltage
as a function of time,
so this is voltage as
a function of time,
when we inject a step of
current into the cell.
So what's going to happen?
So the cell starts
at some voltage,
and the current turns on.
What's going to happen?
Some fresh [INAUDIBLE].
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Excellent.
Like that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MICHALE FEE: Very good.
Then what's going to happen?
Yeah.
Excellent-- like that.
And then what's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: So we inject a
constant current into our cell,
and now our cell is
going to generate
spikes, action potentials,
at regular intervals.
And the interval
between those spikes
is going to be controlled by
how long it takes that capacitor
to charge up from the reset
voltage to the threshold.
So we can actually just
very simply calculate
the firing rate of this
neuron as a function
of how much current we
inject into the cell.
So the firing rate is
just 1 over that interval
between the spikes.
So now what do we do?
Anybody want to guess
what the next step is?
How do we figure out
how long it takes?
We know this distance.
This is kind of like some
third grade word problem here.
Come on, somebody help me out.
You cross a river.
You're paddling one second.
The river's 10 meters across.
Anybody, anybody?
How about right there, white
shirt, what do you think?
Yes.
[LAUGHS]
Well, we're trying
to calculate the time
it takes for the voltage
to go from here to here.
What would it depend on?
Yes?
Yeah.
Well, what are you doing?
Yeah, but what are you--
you're calculating what?
AUDIENCE: Delta t.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, you're
calculating delta t.
And you're using
what about this line?
Slope, exactly.
So if we knew the
slope of this line,
we could calculate how long it
takes to go from here to here.
So let's do that.
So we have this
equation, C, dV, dt
equals I sub E. What's
the slope of this line?
Yeah, it's just dV, dt.
Good.
So it's dV, dt.
That's delta V over delta t.
Delta V is just this
voltage difference, right?
And delta t is what we're
trying to calculate.
So we just solve--
we just plug this
into here, and we just
solve for 1 over delta t.
And that's just C delta V
times the injected current.
That's probably what
you were saying, right?
Any questions about that?
So let's look at
what that looks like.
The firing rate is proportional
to the projected current.
It goes through 0.
At 0 injected current,
the voltage is constant
and the neuron will never fire.
But if we inject a
tiny bit of current,
the voltage will slowly ramp
up, and it will eventually
hit the threshold
and then reset.
So the firing rate is
proportional to the injected
current slope 1 over C
delta V. If the capacitor
is much bigger, what
happens to the firing rate?
It slows down, because
as you inject current,
the voltage increases more
slowly because the capacitance
is bigger.
Now, let's add our leak
conductance back in.
So this leak
conductance, we're going
to think of it as a
potassium conductance.
So I'm going to call it
"G leak," because I'm
going to use something like that
later in Hodgkin-Huxley model,
but you should
think about it just
as a potassium conductance.
So what's going to happen?
Let's go to our plot of
voltage as a function of time
during our injected current.
Let's say that we start at V
reset, our voltage at V reset.
Or actually, let's
start it E leak.
Now what happens, anybody?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It
relaxes [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Good.
The voltage starts here, because
there's 0 injected current.
As soon as you inject current,
V infinity jumps up to here,
let's say.
The voltage relaxes
exponentially
toward V infinity until it
hits the threshold-- very good.
Then what happens?
Somebody else.
Yeah?
How about you in the gray shirt.
AUDIENCE: It drops.
MICHALE FEE: Great.
So if you know the
answer, raise your hand.
We'll go much faster.
So at this point, it will
jump back down to where?
Good.
And then what.
Anybody else?
If you know the answer,
raise your hand.
Let's just do an exercise.
Raise your hand,
everybody who knows--
up high.
Raise your hand up high.
Now, one of you say it.
[LAUGHTER]
Everybody, say it.
AUDIENCE: It's relaxes.
MICHALE FEE: Great,
music to my ears.
It relaxes exponentially
back V infinity
until it hits threshold
and it jumps back.
It keeps doing it.
Now, what happens here?
The current turns off.
What happens?
Who knows the answer
to that question?
Raise your hands up high.
Shout it out.
AUDIENCE: It goes back to the--
AUDIENCE: It relaxes.
MICHALE FEE: Excellent.
It relaxes back to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Why is it
a leak, not V reset?
When there's no current
injected, that's V infinity.
So that's why it
relaxes back to E leak.
Any questions?
No?
It's pretty simple, right?
So it's pretty simple.
And we can actually
derive the expression now
for this delta t,
and therefore, we
can drive the equation
for the firing rate
as a function of
injected current.
It's a little more complicated
than the other one.
I'm going to go through it
in a little bit less detail,
because the answer
turns out to actually
be pretty simple [AUDIO OUT].
So we're going to calculate the
firing rate, which is just 1
over this delta t here.
Before we actually
get into the math,
what happens if v
infinity is down here?
Who knows the answer
to that question?
Raise your hands.
Shout it out.
It won't spike, right?
Good.
So V infinity actually has
to be above V threshold
in order for that
neuron to spike.
Does that makes sense?
So something is
different already,
because before we
found in the current
we injected the cell
would eventually spike.
But now what we see is
when we have a leak,
the V infinity actually has
to be above V threshold.
And so that means there's
going to be some threshold
current below which
the neuron won't spike.
That's pretty cool.
We can see that right away.
So I just wanted to
find one quantity,
called the "rheobase," and
that is that current at which
the neuron begins to spike.
So if we start our
cell at V reset,
because let's say
it just spiked,
so it relaxes exponentially
toward V infinity,
but let's say that V infinity
is right at threshold.
So you can see that the
time to reach the threshold
is actually very long.
If V infinity is
equal to V threshold,
it will never actually reach it.
Even when V infinity is
equal to V threshold,
the firing rate is 0.
Because if you inject just
a tiny bit more current,
now it'll begin to spike.
It can calculate
the injected current
required to reach threshold.
That's called the rheobase.
We just set V infinity
equal to V threshold, right?
And we use our equation for--
that's V infinity, and we just
set it equal to threshold.
Now we just derive
the injected current
we just solved for
I sub E. That's
the injected current
required to make V infinity
reach V threshold,
and you can see
that it's just G leak times
V threshold minus E leak.
And we call that I threshold.
So here's the way it looks.
The firing rate of this
neuron is 0 for low currents.
As you inject more current,
V infinity increases,
but the cell still
can't reach threshold
until you inject an
amount of current,
such that V infinity
reaches V threshold,
and then it begins to spike.
And the firing rate increases
rapidly, and then going up.
Does that makes sense?
So many neurons
have that property
of having a threshold current
above which you have to--
below which the
cell won't spike.
So now let's actually
derive the equation
for this firing rate as a
function of injected current.
So here's how we're
going to do that.
The cell just spiked,
and we're going
to calculate the amount of time
before the cell spikes again.
So we're going to start
the voltage at V reset.
We know that at some injected
current above threshold
the cell relaxes
exponentially to V infinity.
And we're just going to
calculate how long it
takes equal to threshold.
So you know that that's
an exponential, right?
In fact, we wrote down the
solution to that exponential
a bunch of times.
The difference from
V to V infinity
decreases exponentially.
But we know a bunch of
these values, right?
We know that we're calculating
these voltages when tau equals,
sorry, when t equals delta t.
And we know the initial
voltage, that's V reset.
And we know the voltage
at time delta t,
and that's just
equal to V threshold.
So we can just substitute those
quantities into this equation.
So now we have V [AUDIO OUT]
minus V infinity equals V reset
minus V infinity times E to
the minus delta t over tau.
Does that make sense?
Everyone see what I just did?
We're just calculating this
time that it takes the neuron
to relax exponentially from
V reset to V threshold.
We know all these
quantities, so we just
stick them into this equation.
And what do we solve for?
Delta t, good.
So we take the
natural log of-- well,
we divide through
by V reset minus V
infinity, take the natural
log, and we solve for delta t.
So delta t equals minus tau,
natural log, V infinity minus V
threshold over V
infinity minus V reset.
It's kind of messy, right?
I don't know.
The shape of that doesn't
really leap to my mind.
So what we're going
to do is actually just
simplify this
expression in a limit,
in a limit that the
injected current is large.
So what happens here when the
injected current is large?
What gets big?
V infinity gets big, right?
When you inject
a lot of current,
V infinity is very high.
Does that make sense?
And when V infinity
is really big,
this expression approaches what?
1.
And what is the log of 1?
AUDIENCE: 0.
MICHALE FEE: 0.
So this expression, this
expression approaches 1,
and this expression, the
log of that, approaches 0.
So we can do is do a linear
approximation of this turn
right here.
So here's what
we're going to do.
We're going to work in
the limit that V infinity
is much bigger than V
reset or V threshold.
We're going to use the
approximation that log
of 1 plus alpha is just alpha.
So as this approaches 1, you
can write it as 1 plus alpha.
That whole thing there
approximates to alpha.
And when you do that and you
solve for the firing rate, what
you find is that the
firing rate is just 1
over C delta V times
the injected current
minus the threshold current.
Threshold current
is just the rheobase
that we calculated before.
Well, what does that look like?
Well, what is the firing
rate, first of all?
I kind of simplified this a bit.
What is the firing rate when the
current is below I threshold?
0.
And then if it's above I
threshold-- so this expression
that I wrote right
here is true only
if the injected current
greater than I threshold.
And it's zero below that.
So now, what does
this look like?
The firing rate is 0
until you hit threshold.
And then what?
It increases--
AUDIENCE: Linearly.
MICHALE FEE: --linearly.
So this equation is linearly
in the injected current.
The slope is actually exactly
the same as it was for the case
where there was no leak.
So the fine rate is 0.
Once you hit the threshold,
the firing rate of the neuron
increases approximately
linearly for large currents.
And if you look down here, what
you see is that the current
actually--
the actual solution is
that the firing rate
jumps up at threshold
and then tracks
along the linear approximation.
So the dashed line there
is the actual solution.
The solid line is that
linear approximation.
And that right there is
really a very good model
for a lot of neurons.
Most neurons sort of
saturate a little bit.
Their firing rate kind of
flattens out a little bit
as you go to very
high firing rates.
But that's a pretty
good approximation.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: Delta
V is the difference
from V reset to V threshold.
Those are just
parameters of the model.
There was another question here.
Skyler?
AUDIENCE: I had
the same question.
MICHALE FEE: Same question?
OK.
Anything else?
That's the integrate
and fire neuron.
That's probably the
most commonly used model
of neurons in neuroscience--
pretty simple.
Or I should say, that's the
most commonly used model
of spiking neurons.
So you can actually take
neurons that behave like this,
and assemble them
into complex networks,
and study how network
interactions occur
with a spiking model.
And this model captures most
of the interesting, important
behavior of spiking neurons.
Question, Danny?
Any other questions?
So let's come back to
our Hodgkin-Huxley model,
our equivalent circuit.
So what we just described
was a model neuron
in which we replaced
these sodium and potassium
conductances that actually
produce these action
potentials with a very
simple spike generator.
But now what we're
going to do is
we're going to come
back to our model,
and we're going to flesh out
the biophysical details that
allow these two conductances
right here to produce
action potentials.
Now, in fact, most
of the time when
we model networks of neurons,
we simplify the spike generator
to something like an integrate
and fire spike generator.
But the framework that
Hodgkin and Huxley developed
for describing a time-dependent
and voltage-dependent
conductances is so
powerful and commonly used
to describe conductances that
it's really worth understanding
that mathematical description,
that physical description,
of ionic conductances
and how they
depend on voltage and time.
So that's what we're
going to do next.
So the first thing
we do is we notice
that in the Hodgkin-Huxley model
we have three conductances.
We have conductance
which is very
much like the lead
conductance that we just
used in the integrate
and fire model.
It has a reversal potential
of around minus 50 millivolts,
and it's just always on.
It's just constant conductance.
We have these two other
conductances, a sodium
conductance and a
potassium conductance,
that are both time-dependent
and voltage-dependent.
Each one of those
conductances as
has a current
associated with it,
currents flowing
through ion channels.
The total membrane
current is just the sum
of all of those currents.
That's just definition.
The total ionic
membrane current is just
the sum of contributions from
sodium channels, potassium
channels, and a leak.
So the equation for our
Hodgkin-Huxley model,
again using Kirchhoff's
current law,
the sum of all the currents
into these nodes has equal 0.
So the membrane ionic current
plus the capacitive current
equals the injected
electrode current.
Now, each one of
these conductances,
or each one of these
currents, can be written down
in the same form that
we developed before
for our potassium conductance.
It's just a, sorry, for
the potassium current.
So the sodium current is just a
sodium conductance times what?
What is that?
Driving potential, right?
The driving
potential for sodium.
But the sodium conductance now
is voltage- and time-dependent.
And it's that voltage
and time dependence
that gives sodium channels
the properties that they need
to generate action potentials.
It's just analogous to
what we already did before
for the potassium conductance.
And here's the
potassium current.
It's just GK times the driving
potential for potassium,
and the potassium conductance
is voltage- and time-dependent.
Again, EK is minus
75, ENA is plus 55.
And our leak conductance,
the leaked current rather,
is just the leak conductance
times the driving potential
for the leak current.
The difference is
that, in this model
now, the leak conductance
is just constant.
There's no time dependence,
it's always there,
and its voltage independent.
Any questions about that?
So the name of the game
here in understanding
how this thing works
is to figure out
where this time dependence and
voltage dependence comes from.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: They're very close.
The potassium equilibrium
potential is always very close
to minus 75.
In some neurons, it might
be as low as minus 95,
but it's always in that range.
The sodium reversal potential
is always plus 50-ish.
Well, it's highly
consistent across mammals,
and the numbers for squid are
pretty close to that as well.
I think these are the
numbers for squid that
come from Hodgkin and Huxley.
Questions?
Now, how do these things
generate an action potential?
That's the next question.
Just in principle,
how do you think
about conductances like this
generating action potentials?
So let's say that the
conductances here are 0.
We set those to 0.
Those little arrows mean
variable or adjustable.
So we can imagine that we
have our hand on the knob,
and let's just turn
those both down to 0.
So what's the voltage
in the cell going to be?
So what does the cell do?
Well, if this is one
of those moments where
everybody knows the answer and
they're just not saying it--
anybody?
Skylar?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
So roughly, it's close to that.
It's minus 50, in this case.
Good.
So if these conductances
are 0, then the cell
is going to be sitting at
the vault of this battery.
There's 0 current,
steady state, 0 current.
The voltage drop across here is
0, because there is 0 current.
And so the inside of
the cell had better
be sitting at that voltage
of that battery, which
is minus 50.
So now, what happens if we
suddenly turn on a conductance?
What do I mean by "turn
on a conductance"?
We make the resistance
really small,
or we make the
conductance really big.
So what are we doing?
Let's turn that conductance
on as much as possible,
which means we're setting
that resistor to 0.
Actually, if this
resistance is 0,
then the voltage drop across--
the voltage inside
has to just be--
it has to be set to the
voltage of that battery.
Does that make sense?
Well, if we have no
conductance here,
then the voltage inside the
cell will relax toward e sub l.
But if we now turn
on this conductance,
we set that resistor
to 0, the voltage
will jump up that resistor
back up to some big value.
What's the voltage going to do?
Relax back to e sub l.
So Daniel made this nice
simulation of what happens.
So here's what is
going to happen.
These conductances are
going to start at 0.
We're going to-- oh, wait.
These conductances
are to start at 0,
and then we're going to
make this resistor small--
not 0, but small.
Then we're going to
make this resistor big,
and we're going to make
that resistor small.
So watch what happens.
So the conductances are going
to be plotted along the bottom,
and the voltage of
the cell is going
to be plotted as a
function of time here.
And the green and red show
the reversal potentials
for the sodium and potassium.
There, the sodium conductance
just got turned on.
And what happened?
The voltage of the cell
jumps up to [INAUDIBLE] when
we turn on the
potassium conductance,
and we turn off the
sodium conductance,
and the voltage gets
dragged down to EK.
Then when we turn off the
potassium conductance,
the voltage relaxes
back up to [INAUDIBLE]..
So look, conductances
are just knobs
that allow the cell to
control its voltage--
an anthropomorphic
way to put it.
You can control the
voltage of the cell
just by setting the
values of those resistors.
If you make this resistor really
small and that resistor big,
the voltage jumps up
toward [INAUDIBLE]..
Why is that?
Because you're connecting
the inside of the cell
to that battery.
Turn that off, and then
turn on this conductance,
or setting that resistor
to be very small,
now you're connecting
the inside of your cell
to this battery, which
is negative, down here.
So you can just control the
voltage of the cell up and down
just by twiddling these knobs.
Another way to think
about it is this.
If this resistor is big,
and if you set that resistor
to be really small, then
the voltage here dominates.
So over the timescale of any
process that we're considering
here, the ionic concentrations
inside the cell and outside
of the cell don't change.
Does that make sense?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if we
set both of them?
MICHALE FEE: So you
set both of these to 0?
AUDIENCE: Not 0.
[INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: If the
conductance is really high,
that means setting the
resistors really small.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
MICHALE FEE: That's
a great question.
What happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that like--
MICHALE FEE: That's
exactly right.
If you set both of
these, if you turn
on both of these
conductances, then the voltage
goes somewhere in the middle.
And the voltage that it
goes to is actually--
you have to [AUDIO OUT].
The Nernst potential
that we calculated
is calculated only for the
case where you have one ion.
If you want to calculate the
equilibrium potential when
you have multiple
pores open, then
you have to use a different
method of calculating.
You have to actually
calculate the currents flowing
in each one of those
channels, and based
on the permeabilities
of the channels,
and you get a
different expression,
called the
Goldman-Hodgkin-Katz equation.
But the bottom line
is, if you open up
both of those conductances,
it's somewhere in the middle.
And if you want to get
the exact right answer,
you have to use
the GHK equation.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Almost.
We're not quite there yet.
We're going to get there.
But you can see
what happens here
is that these conductances are
actually voltage-dependent.
So for example, the
sodium conductance
turns on at higher voltages.
When this conductance
starts getting bigger,
what happens to the
voltage in the cell?
It starts going up, right?
But if this is
voltage-dependent and it
turns on at a
higher voltage, what
happens to the conductance?
When the voltage gets
a little bit bigger,
what happens to the conductance,
which does what to the voltage?
Makes it go up
even faster, right?
And so you get this
runaway process
where the disconductance
turns on very quickly
and the voltage jumps up.
That's the essence of
the action potential.
But the essential
picture that I wanted
you to get from this slide
is that these are just knobs.
And when you turn
the knobs, you can
change the volt-- that controls
the voltage in the cell.
Each one of these
is causing the cell
to be dragged toward
its reversal potential.
So if this conductance is
big, this conductance is big,
the voltage in the cell
gets dragged toward ENA.
If the conductance is big,
the voltage in the cell
gets dragged toward EK.
And next time, we're going
to go through the process.
We're going to
describe the process
to drive the voltage
dependence of those ion
channels, the sodium and
potassium ion channels,
to derive the voltage dependence
and the time dependence that
explains how you get this
action potential in a neuron.
So that's next Tuesday.